the reason i uh
tended to the idea that the mushroom
might be an extraterrestrial was because
of this weird way in which it approaches
you when you take it that it presents
itself as another as a being with whom
you can have a dialogue and that it's
loaded with all this information and
imagery about alien life forms societies
technologies all of this stuff i mean if
this is my imagination that can call up
hours of cinemascope
movies about the histories and machinery
and social relations of alien species i
don't know exactly what to make of it
i think probably we have a very
parochial view
of what biology is capable of and that
it's quite possible that the mushroom is
an extraterrestrial that we have
possessed radio
for about 100 years
in some form and our assumption then
that radio is the means by which any
intelligent life form in the universe
would communicate with any other is
probably
as preposterous as somebody who believed
that you would do it with drums if
that's what they were into you know
uh
trying to i think the major thing about
trying to imagine an extraterrestrial
is the problem is not to find
extraterrestrials but to recognize them
and all the extraterrestrials of science
fiction and movies are so preposterously
like us as to be dismissed immediately i
mean i don't care if you do have a
splayed end on your middle finger
if you're walking around with binocular
vision and that sort of thing while
you're just a carbon copy of a human
being
biology i'll bet you is capable of
things that we can barely conceive of or
imagine that are living and intelligent
the first thing you have to remember
when you talk about
extraterrestrials is that probably
anyone who could carry out a program of
contact across the stars has a complete
knowledge of dna
and is therefore probably does not
display the form that they evolved in on
their planet of origin but displays
whatever form they have chosen to design
themselves into
the mushroom
looks to me like an engineered life form
it it looks to me it's almost all brain
because what it is is it's this mycelial
mat
in the soil
circulating this drug compound which is
very much like a neurotransmitter in
fact very much like serotonin the
mushroom
the physical the so-called carpaphor is
just is involved in the sexual cycle of
the mushroom and is just something that
it can occasionally
produce when it feels the need to
sporulate but it's perfectly capable of
vegetatively propagating itself without
ever sporulating and even undergoing
renewal of the genome by that means so
it's like it has two forms of
reproduction
it's uh
the fact that it produces
spores
which are the color of uh that we paint
spacecraft that we want to
reflect ultraviolet radiation this dark
purple black
the fact that these spores last longest
in the laboratory under conditions that
most closely approximate those of space
i.e ultra cold dark desiccated
environments they will last indefinitely
and then the message you know i mean i
why should it say that it's very
interesting see in the 60s um
psilocybin was made illegal when
lsd was made illegal because there was
just they swept the floor basically and
made it all illegal on one day but
really there was no psilocybin any there
was was very in very small amounts and
probably of dubious synthesis or maybe
it was only said to be psilocybin anyway
psilocybin did not play a role in what
happened in the 1960s
it was only in 1975 when we published
this book and other people followed on
that suddenly people could grow it and
what had become you know a legend
something you had to go to watla or
further south to experience became
available to everybody and it's
interesting to go back through like the
san francisco oracle or tim leary's
early books and notice the complete
absence of the extraterrestrial theme
it wasn't viewed that way the
psychedelic experience as defined by the
editors of the san francisco oracle
didn't have elves and gremlins and
flying saucers associated with it was
basically an aphrodisiac
psychoanalytic life affirming
social
hallucinogen
of some sort
part of the motivation of my career is
to try and get people to look at this
phenomenon psychologists this is what i
will tell the ahp when i go back there
to boston is that something has been
missed
there is a mythology i think among
mushroom takers
that of the saucer of the animate
quality that this thing is intelligent
and that it desires a symbiotic
relationship with man and it's not hard
to see why because it's a real
breakthrough for a species to cut a deal
with human beings then you come in from
the cold you're no longer subject to
the vicissitudes of darwinian selection
you've become a domesticated plant from
now on or animal from now on your fate
is entirely linked to the fate of all
the other domesticated plants and
animals and their husbandmen the human
race
and so for a plant to become
to go from a wild crop to being a food
crop virtually ensures its survival into
the untold future
so it's a very if you think of plants
and animals as seeking better adaptive
stances in the environment you could
hardly do better than to bring yourself
to the attention of human beings and get
them to cultivate you that means when we
go to space
they will go to space
when the human race leaves the planet we
will take thousands and thousands of
plants and animals and bacteria and
fungi and insects all these things will
go with us we are the point species
for this process of leaving the planet
but i'm sure from the planetary
ecosystems point of view
we're just doing it for all the other
little furry folk and their friends you
know
we're
acting for everybody and everybody will
it will benefit everyone
i think we're about to go
that you know when the comets come
they'll find that man is just a fading
memory in the fossil record of earth and
that we are long gone
[Music]
you